Trust only your own leaders trust them
and question everything.
Be Wise. Question everything. Question
your leaders don't follow people blindly.
You can put your trust in them. Sure.
But at the same time you have to be wise,
be wise to question them, be wise to
try and understand their decisions.
Be Wise enough to disobey them should
they choose to lead in a manner that is
detrimental to the mission and to
common sense. And you don't want,
you got to be why not just about
your leaders behind everything.
Seek to understand people,
which you do by watching and by observing
them and by listening to then you know
we spend a lot of time on output.
We are sending all the time.
We are talking all the time. We are
putting information out all the time,
received mode a little bit more.
I've learned to listen a little bit
more to learn to capture and absorb and
utilize what other people revealed.
And when you do that and you garner a
better understanding of them, of yourself,
of your team, of your hand. To me,
the nature of the battle itself
and the nature of humans.
So listen inward and understand so that
you can be calm wise if you become wise,
that you can win.